the big studios are turning against
Disney and Netflix CEOs they're telling
them pack it in stop acting like a child
and get on with a job at hand welcome to
CRA your sa TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel when The Writers Guild of
America agreed their deal with the
studios it was gen expected that the
actor strike would follow and that this
Studios and sag after would agree a deal
within just a couple of weeks the big
studios like Amazon Etc were genuinely
expecting November 1st to be the date
where they could get back to work they
were hoping that they still might be
able to get a couple of the Christmas
specials and things like that done
before December at least something and
100% they were hoping to get big
projects like Daredevil and things like
that back up and running their studios
are sat empty all of that studio space
costs a fortune all those sets and all
those sets sat around doing nothing they
desperately wanted to get back to work
so why on Earth did the studio bosses
walk out just a week ago and end
negotiations again throwing everything
upside down well according to my sources
that are reasonably close to this
apparently Netflix and Disney Disney
were the main reasons why the
negotiations collapsed again Disney's
Bob Iger and Netflix's Ted sados walked
out now apparently there were a few
reasons for this but one of the big ones
was this Demand by the actor's guild to
put in this sort of like 2% levy on
subscribers for things like Netflix Etc
so 2% of saying Netflix's subscription
count was then going to be going towards
paying the actors now apparently the
actus Guild said give us 2% Netflix Etc
went not a chance so they went one and
Bob Iger and Ted walked the hell out now
apparently the rest of the studio sort
of had to follow because those are the
main two players and actually the head
of negotiations is the guy over at
Netflix so they didn't have a choice but
they were
Furious now I've been talking to
somebody that's very close to sort of
the Amazon side of things as you know I
have quite good sources over there and
they were basically saying people like
Jennifer S head of MGM pictures and
Amazon pictures and her boss Bob Hopkins
were Furious there was several big
meetings and they got a load of the
other people across like David zaslav
and Donna Langley Donna Langley is from
NBC Universal and zaslav is from Warner
Brothers Discovery were called in and
they had a big conference meeting
apparently on Thursday Friday they were
basically saying Disney and Netflix are
ruining this for all of us and they're
costing us a fortune we need a deal they
then got in touch with their
counterparts over at Netflix and Disney
and said pack it in we need to get this
sorted we need a deal that works for
everybody we are losing tens of millions
of dollars every damn week and it's got
to stop we all agreed November 1st stop
messing around and get a deal now
negotiations we hear are to start again
on Tuesday they will be going back to
negotiations they will be offering a new
deal and that deal will be much closer
to what the actor's guild has been
asking for now sagra they're not going
to get everything they want but the
longer this goes on and the closer to
November 1st that we get the more they
will get so if anybody over at sagaa is
watching my little video please hold on
on for just a little bit longer you may
get just a little bit more money for the
trouble the studios particularly Amazon
apparently I'm hearing they're really at
the front of this and Warner Brothers to
be fair are desperate for this deal to
get sorted they are absolutely sick to
death of this and one source I've been
talking to as well is just talking me
about this negotiation actually only
sorts out the contract for three years
one of the big meetings that they're
having sort of like thrashing this out
they were pointing out that this is all
going to going again in three years time
and we cannot basically go on strike for
three months every three years we just
can't we need to have a much better
working relationship with these people
and we need actually a long-term
strategy to avoid these strikes in
future now what that longterm strategy
is well I suspect the plan is to smash
the unions eventually move production
away from actually places that sagaa
control and the wga getting a lot of
production out of America is a start if
you film a lot of your stuff in Asia
Britain or elsewhere with actors that
aren't members of sagaa these constant
strikes are really not going to be a
problem anymore and you can pay actors
whatever you like at the end of the day
this is going to be a little bit like
the car industry over here in the UK in
like the 80s the car industry kept going
on strike kept demanding more money
so the car industry died we now only
build cars in this country for other
people all of the big British car
companies are gone and the car companies
that we have left like mg are actually
just built in China that might be the
future for Hollywood if it's not very
very
careful but for now the studios Amazon
Warner Brothers Etc are kicking Netflix
and Disney back into the negotiation
room
and hopefully we'll get something very
very soon have a look at the TV guide
and seeing what TV shows going to be
airing soon there's not
many we are now actually starting to see
the impact of the writers and the actors
strike and I don't know about you but
I'm already bored of it we need them to
get back to work so that we can have
something to look forward to damn it
it's Christmas after all nearly come on
so let's see what happens but guys get
into to the comments and tell me what
you think Netflix and Disney are they
just taking the absolute Michael now do
they just need to get on with it and
give the actors something that they can
live with or actually have the studios
got a point are the actors the ones
taking the mick asking for just too much
a lot of the studios owe a crapload of
money is it just not the right time for
the actors to be out there like Oliver
with a ball going please sir give give
me some
more I don't know but get to comment and
tell me what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps us
out and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to c.co which is
our dedicated website where we do
articles based on most of our stories
and we try to throw in a little bit more
detail for you to digest finally there's
patreon.com sidre where you get to see
most of our new videos first and for a
small contribution each month that
really supports the channel you get to
see them without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next
[Music]
time